[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay this is really gonna date me i
remember playing pathways into darkness
back in 1993 on my original mac and that
game was phenomenal then marathon oh i
would troll the aol message boards for
the news of the release of the demo and
i tried to download that demo on a 14-4
modem with people picking up the phone
it would took forever marathon 2 and
marathon infinity the best title music
in marathon 2 and marathon infinity i
would take pictures of my star wars
figures and put them into the game using
forge and anvil
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
30
years
of creating the games that we love games
i've grown up playing
throughout my childhood
teenage years
and also my adult life
from the ogs
games i started on halo 2's and the halo
3s
winning championships in these games
from the collectibles and reach
amazing amazing artsmanship
craftsmanship designing coding all these
timeless hours you guys have put in to
create these worlds
we need to get back to the city it isn't
safe here from the destiny 1
sanitary and all
of the law that you started with
more collectibles
all the way to destiny 2.
[Music]
pick up
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
from egm giving combat evolve game of
the month and perfect tens to lan
parties to xbox live
to the thank you screen on reach to the
d1 alpha
to my girlfriend showing up on the
corner of my bed with the destiny ps4 to
play with me
to rifted e3 and the blacksmith's shader
to getting to see destiny 2 at e3 with
tess to her marrying me
and old friends still playing halo at
our wedding
to day one deep stone crypt
to so many raids so many friends and a
test still playing destiny with me every
week
bungie has personally given me
20 years of fantastic memories and i am
forever grateful
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
as a content creator i strive to build
my community on positivity and
compassion my community at tcat has
involved into such an important part of
my life and has helped me create
lifelong friendships i've met so many
amazing people online and in real life
because of the extravagant world created
by bungie and a little old game called
destiny
some of my favorite memories include
traveling to bungie to reveal the taken
king
going to gcx and meeting so many amazing
people and raising money for saint jude
i will cherish all of these memories and
i cannot wait to make more
[Music]
oh
ah
[Music]
bunji
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
so my clan peasant guard was formed
through a love of destiny and it's made
up of plays from the uk america and
norway and my favorite bungee moment
something that will stay with me forever
is after a year of playing together
online we were all contacted by bungie
and asked if we'd like to be flown out
to germany to meet in person and to have
that moment captured in a mini
documentary and that like happened over
six years ago now and it always brings a
smile to my face whenever i think about
it so yeah no question that was my
favorite bungee moment
[Music]
[Music]
i am a former drug addict and playing
destiny one kicked my drug addiction and
on my five year silver mark i actually
got the titan hunter warlock
uh class logos tattooed on me um and i
also want to thank you guys for
consistently putting out great games
that help build a community i have a lot
of my friends worldwide both here in the
us uk
australia um and um the um
europe um from plain destiny and destiny
1. so happy birthday bunji and those are
two of my main bungee memories
[Music]
[Music]
i think it all starts with going home
after school like every day and playing
halo 3 custom games all night trash
compactor
tremors.com so many fantastic options
stay away to heaven and then i think the
moment i really got into destiny and
just fell in love with that game was
during the vault of glass
back then exotics are really uncommon
and one of our teammates had a hard
light no one had ever seen it before so
we're all like dude what the heck is
that gun and he just goes
watch this and of course start shooting
off the walls and we see all the bullets
ricochet everywhere and it was at that
moment i knew
i was hooked
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
destiny
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
flash forward to me as an adult
discovering destiny for the first time
walking out of the cosmodrome seeing
that fallen walker taking it down and
just feeling like such a
just just such an awesome powerful force
to be reckoned with i was in love with
the fantasy of the game
uh and that was before i knew anything
of the destiny community which really
has captured my heart thank you so much
bunji for creating this world uh this
community of gamers uh where i've found
real friends clan mates uh been able to
talk to people and interact with people
who have inspired me
throughout the years to to launch my own
community
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my favorite memory from a bungee game
has to come from september 2016.
it's a work night and we're about done
with a wrath and machine raid when my
friend messages us and says you know
that arg puzzle that bunji put out
we solved it here's a map
go stand in these very specific spots in
the raid and see what happens so we do
it and these two monitors turn on and
they start spitting out ones and zeros
and someone on the team's like that's
binary i think that means we need to
stand here and over there
then
the mysterious diamond in the center of
the room opens up revealing the next
step in a quest to get outbreak prime an
exotic weapon and we're
losing it i stay up all night finishing
the quest i get maybe two hours of sleep
before work the next day
figuring out how to open up the diamond
and the wrath of the sheen raid
is my favorite memory because it
combines the two things about bungee
games that keeps me coming back
unraveling mysteries
and sharing experiences with other
people
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like there really have been so many
special memories
um i had two recurring trials dates
every week when trials of osiris was
going on one of them was for dr bro
snaps and then the other one was on
monday nights i would play trials of
chill cyrus
with some friends that i met online
one of them
dopa
uh i got to go to his wedding a couple
of years ago which was really cool we've
been friends irl now for years
and the other one
is my boyfriend of five years now
and
i still can't believe
how crazy it is that destiny brought me
to twitch which introduced us to each
other and as a result now
we have
another little guardian
[Laughter]
she's a future hunter maine for sure
but she quite literally would not exist
if it wasn't for bungie slash destiny
and trials of osiris
[Music]
ah
[Music]
i think
one of my another one of my favorite
moments was the d2 reveal event
and i don't think there will ever be an
event that will
match that and i could be wrong but the
room was shaking
like everyone was so excited everyone
was screaming you didn't have to tell
them to get excited because you could
feel the energy in the room everyone was
hyped it just but there was like this
vibration in the room of how excited
everyone was and
and it was just i remember just holding
watts's hands
while the trailer was going on and
zavala just
came down
bubbled up and i'm pretty sure we cried
together we cried while holding hands
watching
the cinematic trailer for the d2
event so i remember that being such a
huge huge moment and i just i just knew
that i was a part of something that was
way way way bigger than i thought
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think that my favorite bunchy memories
are always probably going to be my
childhood lan parties i would have
growing up with my friends and then even
into college with like halo reach when
it launched i remember running down to
like the college store and
getting my copy there
uh but as an adult
i don't think i could ever replace the
memories i have about the day one rating
i've done with my friends
just
being faced with a colossal challenge
and defeating it with some of your best
friends there's just nothing quite like
it
[Music]
[Music]
my clan math class in 2016
rented out a house for pax and easily
one of my favorite memories
through all of this has been
being in that house with them for a few
days just hanging out everybody chilling
together and just having a really really
good time so
i never would have had that without uh
without
bungie and destiny so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh man some memories man the memories
that really really truly brought me back
was destiny one and we played auto glass
week two we didn't play it on the week
of release we played it on week two and
when we first experienced the race me
and the boys from work um i didn't
really know too many people we went in
that raid man we defeated the first uh
encounter we beated the first encounter
[Music]
[Music]
you know the thing about bungie memories
for me is that it's memories of my
friends because bungie games are about
friends it's four friends sitting in a
room everybody with their own xbox
everybody with their own tv and
everybody yelling at each other because
the one person keeps bringing the
gravity hammer into the elevator killing
all of us it's
destiny with a crew
six people tired long night you haven't
beat the raid boss and you want to beat
that rate boss and the last run it works
and you yell for 25 minutes before you
log off
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i had just moved to the states and the
very first friend that i made here was a
guardian that i found in the cosmodrome
and that guardian has been my best
friend and brother for five years now
and that was only
the beginning of a very special
relationship
with destiny for me
some of the most beautiful moments my
life have been driven and shared by the
destiny community including coming out
and watching
hundreds of people
that i didn't even know
um just come together to show love and
support and solidarity
in that moment i knew that i had found a
home away from home
and this game and this community
constantly reminds me that
we're not guardians just a name we truly
are bearers of light
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up man yeah if you guys just
wanted to see it's literally recording a
conversation so
right what could go wrong
so i was um
i was 11
when you started when you started the
company but you were you're i mean
but
you're not that much older like you
weren't that much older like what
what is the like take me all the way
back that's true yeah take me all the
way back to the like
the moment where you're like i want to
do this yeah yeah yeah there's this
there's a funny thing for like a lot of
my life
when people would ask me you know like
how did how did this start i'd be like i
don't know it was kind of weird i just
like started making
games and it seemed like it was fun and
i kept doing it and when i when i really
started thinking back to my childhood
like i've been i've been obsessed with
how
like rules
can change human behavior and how you
can
all agree to play a card game by a
certain set of rules and you know you
know the adults that i was observing you
know as a kid would they could
play cards all night and laugh and you
know interact in
whatever way that they did and
yet you could take a different set of
rules for example a set of rules that a
five-year-old made with the best of
intentions
and the adults would like nod and laugh
but they would only play that game for
you know three minutes
[Laughter]
and like that is like always fascinated
me and i i realized like looking back on
it that i've been doing that
you know my whole life and it like
irritated my friends and they didn't
want to play i mean because we start as
a game designer and you suck like you're
terrible like your games are are a [ __ ]
but they're even games they're just it i
mean it's almost you're just like a
little tyrant trying to get people to do
things and
i remember like building i probably
spent like weeks building this like
really complex uh
pen and paper adventure game on index
cards and i'd like drawn pictures of
monsters and everything like this and i
remember finally getting you know a
friend to play it
at school and it was like the first dice
roll like some creature like killed his
character or something it was just like
the worst possible
you know like outcome and
i was like i mean i was like in fourth
grade or something but some kids look at
the garbage truck and are like that big
powerful machine like that's what i want
to be but to me it was the deck of cards
like i wanted how to control that
like that like power to build an
experience that when people come into it
they
you know they they leave with a smile on
their face they're more connected to the
people around them yeah that's i've been
doing that forever it's kind of it's
kind of crazy way before way before
computers and then of course right i saw
games on computers and i was like wow
my my perception you know based on
all of our time together has actually
been
has been like you are more interested in
the making of them in a bunch of ways
than playing them like playing games
isn't like a
it's not an explicit hobby of yours like
you like you're educating yourself it's
it's more it's more work but it's like
you're like you're always making stuff
yeah i think this is true and i think i
feel a little bit like guilty about it
sometimes because
i think it is the most dangerous thing
as a designer to
enjoy the making more than the playing
right because
the number of things you can enjoy
making is
infinitely larger than the number of
things that
that you can enjoy playing right much
less other people can enjoy playing
and so yeah what you say is true and i
and i feel like it's sort of like an
addiction that i've had to fight so that
i make things that are worthwhile
because i mean because it's you know the
whole shtick to me is about you know
touching other people like somehow yeah
so we talked a little bit about kind of
the
the origin i wanna jump ahead again
i'm gonna jump to my life 2004.
i remember i finished the campaign for
halo 2 and my friends and i got
distracted a bunch by the multiplayer
and i finished it the same night i
finished
middle year three and after i finished
both of those games i went and watched
the spy doc
the the documentary that like i look i i
like it now and i yeah i met a bunch of
y'all and i i'm like oh i didn't pick up
on all the like human suffering
in this documentary the first time the
first time i watched it
[Applause]
i get to sign your uh no do you remember
do you remember this i looked for it
actually before i came in today i don't
i don't think i have it anymore you
don't yeah you know i remember the
sweatshirt yeah okay yeah yeah okay yeah
yeah the so this was this yeah this this
is the this is what is this from
like what is this actually i've like
wondered this like what is this
it was just like what did this yeah i
it's it said osiris on it i thought it
looked cool and yeah i bought i have no
idea i sadly right i have no idea what
it was yeah i still to this day i
literally i remember the sweatshirt
right this is the moment this is this
moment that i became like aware that
humans make these things because
otherwise it was like magic right like
there's nothing like there's nothing in
2004 about look at these developers
making stuff that you care about that's
not there wasn't really much of like the
internet sucked too like you wouldn't
even have like look you could access
these people none of that it was a
totally different time so i'm watching
this this documentary
and you this dude shows up and so the
paraphrase is like you know um
like the
cynical gamers who somebody doesn't grab
us in five minutes
you know we're gonna we're gonna turn it
off and it was like i was like oh my god
it's like i spoke to and i have like no
like i'm like an english degree i'm like
i can't make games i couldn't write any
proto couldn't write code or anything i
just remember i remember feeling as a as
like a player like super duper spoke to
in in that moment and so we come out of
the building a game like building it by
yourself and talk now about like
the team has changed like building teams
has changed like the way you think about
building teams has changed the way bun
like in the however many years i've been
at bungie now and the fifth like the way
the company approaches building teams
have changed let's go all the way back
to halo 2 like
building the team for halo 1 and halo 2.
yeah i mean i i think i think if
like past jason was here he would
yeah he would disagree with a lot of
stuff that
that i'm gonna say but i i think
compared to the intentionality that we
you know try sometimes exhibit you know
know we should have about you know about
building teams and how important teams
are
back then it was almost just this
you know snowball that was rolling
downhill of people who
you know liked our games and came to the
company and you know then you know
snowball rolled a little faster and
it was yeah it was just a bunch of
people trying to do their best trying to
recreate the feelings that they had you
know when they played when they played
games and
you can get pretty far on
on passion and and talent
but it sometimes makes things really
yeah really hard when you're not being
thoughtful about the organization of the
team the design of the product relative
to the resources and time you have and
yeah it made halo 2 super challenging
for a bunch of reasons but
yeah i don't know i guess that's i'm
yeah and and past jason would would tell
me like you're an idiot we were thinking
about all that stuff you just had to
learn but like when i look back like he
wasn't thinking about that stuff
you know what was he thinking about i
mean he was just thinking about the game
but i mean i don't know i always think
i mean i think my past self is like not
really that
sharp because i i mean every year we've
learned
so much i i feel
and so i look back and i think that you
know that guy must be
like i must be an idiot
because look cause look look at all the
stuff i learned just this year
on halo one like i didn't know any i
didn't know anything
but i go back and
yeah i found one of the notebooks from
halo one
like that guy wasn't an idiot like i
mean there's stuff that you know he
didn't know but um there's a lot of like
super interesting exploration and
thought and like possibilities that you
know didn't end up with the game in
there and uh
yeah i don't know i don't know i don't
know what to make of that because i feel
like i feel like i've learned so much
but when i go back i'm i'm sort of like
blown away by
you know what yeah what was what was
happening in in my mind um
yeah
it's pretty embarrassing when i think
about like the i mean i think about my
life in terms of decades and like what's
the what are like the big lessons from
the the decades and as i when i like
articulate one of the like a lesson from
my 30s it's like so embarrassing give me
one from yours yeah
oh man
i mean i really started yeah i started
destiny
one not understanding
the value of having
at least somebody on the you know on the
team who cares more than anybody else
about
yeah what what the team is missing what
the team isn't admitting who on the team
isn't talking to each other where on the
team is our
are our dreams incompatible with the
calendar or our dreams incompatible with
our ability or our dreams incompatible
with the hardware that we need to run on
um
and i saw production as you know a
calendar and a schedule
and
it's true that a schedule is
a thing that you use to sort of test
people's understanding of reality
in the sense of you know can the things
we want to do fit in the time that we
think we have and how are we tracking
against that but i saw it as like an end
in itself and of course it irritated me
and i you know didn't pay attention to
it but god like embracing all that stuff
is a thing that will be yeah front and
center in
anything that i do yeah anything i do in
the future
i think it's making sure everyone on the
team has an objective understanding of
reality and doing anything you can
to fix it when that isn't true i didn't
understand that
when i started destiny 1
destiny 1 made me understand that
so what i want to talk about now is
where computers are heading
where's where's it going
ar is gonna be the thing that displaces
mobile like i'm so i'm so sure of that
i'm so sure we're all gonna be wearing
glasses and all the tvs are gonna go on
a landfill all those companies are going
to go into business all the
cracks in our ceiling are going to get
fixed in our glasses like so many people
are going to end up with virtual pets
and windows out to the taj mahal or the
eiffel tower and
maybe maybe it'll be maybe it'll be 20
years
like i think it's gonna be a lot sooner
than that and i and i think it's gonna
be really interesting and when it
happens like the reason that you're
gonna know it's gonna take over the
whole world is everybody's gonna laugh
at it
like everybody's gonna think it's
ridiculous when the when the iphone
you know came out the stuff people were
saying to like not admit that they were
holding like a
you know chunk of the sun in their hands
that was gonna change the world like the
stuff people said was ridiculous
and and people are going to do that
again and the other interesting thing
about
ar is if you have ar you have to have
local compute because you need high
frame rate you need to be able to render
all kinds of crazy stuff like right
there like you know within two feet of
your body
yeah which means i think that all the
cloud computing stuff totally gonna
happen absolutely gonna be a thing
um
but we're not gonna transition fully to
you know thin thin client but yeah those
those are might be my two predictions
local compute never goes away ar
displaces mobile
like 100
so on a long enough horizon how are we
going to get ready for that
we got we got it's yeah like the you
know so so it yeah it's a i mean it's a
great question and i i i think i think
the answer is
like we are we already are like i don't
think what's going to happen is
there's going to be a whole new slew of
games that
can only happen in ar i mean there's
definitely some
but i think in a lot of cases what's
going to happen is
people are going to
throw away their tv and have a way
bigger tv or they're gonna go to a
totally virtual space that has a bigger
you know screen and they might play some
table top or strategy games
in a different way but i think people
are always gonna be playing first person
shooters
you know with some kind of input device
on like a virtual you know window in
their visual field and so i think a
bunch of the stuff that we're great at
doesn't
yeah get tipped over by this thing we're
great at right so let's go all all the
way back
bungee games
someday
not the company's still there
but i think a lot about my life through
the lens of what would go on my
tombstone i just do i think it's like i
think it's i think it's so i think it's
like completely busted i don't think
it's like a thing a normal
like reasonably sane human being would
do but i think it's a simple way of
summarizing
your existence and it's the
acknowledgement that that these
existences sometimes come to an end the
question i want to ask is about bungie's
epitaph like the like what is that what
is that simple distillation of what
bungie is
the tombstone worthy distillation
i was on the 271 coming back across the
bridge home
yeah one night on the bus and
these two guys in in front of me were
talking
you know at first about college like
they were they were they were older but
they'd obviously like gone to college
together and i think they worked
together
and at some point they started talking
about
halo and i think it was halo 2 for them
and
they weren't really talking about how
much halo meant to them they were
talking about
and they weren't really talking about
how much they meant to each other but
that's what they were doing is they were
sharing those stories of
you know where they were and what they
were doing and how they were
how they were feeling and
you know that that moment you know
that's like still keeping me going i
mean that that might fuel me for the
rest of my life and it's not the only
time that's happened
but you get a few of those and you know
that's all i want it's just
people sharing memories in a in an
experience that
you know wouldn't have existed without
you know you bleeding
buckets of blood into the you know
whatever
code or design or something like that
that's what
yeah
two people having an experience that
they wouldn't have had
um you know if you hadn't created
yeah what you created like that's i
don't know
that's what matters that's what matters
to me
we're done
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're just going right into like the
trailer
this is what i brought you here to see
beyond the lights this is just a tool
it's an ice tornado dude
that was the sickest thing i've ever
seen
it's freaking audrey bow
no
what the
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna shoot you with six anarchies
you're gonna sprint at that gorgon run
run got to be a little doodle run
[Music]
welcome guardians
this year we're celebrating our journey
with you whether you joined us 30 years
ago or if it just started today
this game is in our blood the destiny
team is full of destiny fans folks who
came here because destiny was their
favorite hobby folks who log out from
work in the evening and log in to play
with their clan the team we have today
is committed to relentlessly upgrading
this game that we all love we aren't
happy with just another mission instead
we want to push the limit of quality you
can expect in an action mmo with
uniquely destiny experiences like
expunge and presage we are committed to
delivering the best mission content that
you can play in any game with a friend
and having the best feeling action game
period
and this shows through in the passion
that we see for destiny 2. since we
declared independence two years ago the
destiny community has grown by over 20
million new players and it continues to
grow faster than we ever could have
predicted
we're grateful to be a part of this
amazing growing community that you all
have created you represent destiny you
help make it better every year and you
are so welcoming and supportive of every
new guardian that sets foot in the tower
and only a handful of us are going to be
up here today
most of them are in their homes at their
desks working hard to bring the next
part of destiny to life it's a huge
honor representing such an incredible
team and introducing the next chapter of
destiny 2.
so
without further ado
this
is the witch queen
[Applause]
truth
is a funny thing
does it live in the world
or in the mind
is it constant
or can it be bent
who decides what is true
in this universe of light and dark
there is no greater power
tell me little lights
[Music]
what is your truth now
oh my god james stop bethune is serious
i think she's the most dangerous villain
we faced yet seven years we've been
building up to this moment and she is
finally stepping into the spotlight and
showing us who she really is what we
know about light and darkness is proving
to be way more complex than what we
previously thought there are so many
lies truths and revelations that we're
going to get to in the witch queen and
the year leading up to it i mean we're
paying off these narrative threads that
go all the way back to destiny's origins
and we're supporting it with the best
content that destiny has to offer
definitely and we've got a lot of
awesome content to show today let's
start with the most mysterious
destination yet
sabbath dunes throne world this is an
uncharted wonderland of secrets and lies
it's this place that she's created in
her own image the surreal and majestic
light blessed world she has this castle
that she rules from it overlooks this
dark swampy underbelly with this lone
pyramid ship out there it's the future
world she wanted to create built atop
the darkness that she left behind in
throne worlds they're a deep part of
destiny lore powerful entities create
these pocket universes and when we're
there we have to play by their rules but
now our own light powers are being used
against us i mean she has this whole
army of hive that she's ascended to the
light and brought along with her these
are the hive guardians and they are the
backbone of her new army
we've talked a lot let's show a little
let's take the first ever look at the
witch queen gameplay
the witch queen
hive god of cunning and lies
after the death of her brother oryx
savathun went into hiding
not out of fear of course
but out of strategy
in her greatest trick yet
stealing our most sacred resource
the one thing we thought she could never
touch
the light
[Music]
[Music]
i cannot wait just to reach out and just
crush a high ghost in my hand yeah i
mean we've been defined by the light for
so long this is uncharted territory for
us i mean we're in strange new places
like the throne world is
haunting but it's gorgeous it's
beautiful there's a lot to love there's
a few things we saw on the trail that we
haven't talked about yet sabathune and
her loosened brood this is the biggest
threat guardians have faced yet so we
need to find new weapons to match their
power
the glaive i love this thing it's brutal
and elegant it's this new energy weapon
with melee abilities mid-range
projectiles and defensive capabilities
it's our first ever first person melee
weapon and it is such an awesome tool
for the battlefield
the glade feels so good just jump in and
unleash these brutal melee combos and
transition right to an energy blast
it's really powerful and has a lot of
utility so we've told you about what the
glaive can do
now let's talk about how you're going to
get your hands on one these weapons
don't come out of chest at the end of
missions and you're not going to find
one roaming around the throne world
your first glaive is not going to be
found it's going to be built yes weapon
crafting is coming to destiny 2.
now chasing weapons has been an integral
part of the destiny pursuit game since
the beginning and over the years we've
added more deterministic paths to get
the roles that you want on guns think
things like umbral engrams and the raid
chest weapon crafting unlocks the
freedom to choose all that and more it
gives us ultimate control over the guns
now this is a combat focused crafting
and progression system that means the
more you use these weapons the more
objectives you complete with them the
more you'll level them up and the more
powerful they grow over time and at
launch here's the awesome thing you'll
be able to craft all throne world
weapons new raid weapons and the
seasonal weapons there's just a ton of
stuff to do in this system and the witch
queen is just the beginning of weapon
crafting we have plans to add more
craftable weapons both legacy and new
throughout the year we've seen and we've
talked about a lot of really cool
features but let's get right into the
meat of it let's talk about the witch
queen campaign
i
love campaigns they've always been a
cornerstone of the destiny experience
they're rich deep stories interwoven
with big combat sequences and memorable
characters they take us to remote worlds
in our ever-changing universe and so
we're putting extra care into the
campaign for the witch queen we want you
to feel those goosebumps when you step
onto the throne world for the first time
and come face to face with hive
guardians
and every one of the missions has its
own unique fantasy like what does it
feel like to storm a castle or just go
straight to the depths of hell if you
like games with standalone campaigns
like doom titanfall 2 god war and halo
then the witch queen is for you
so in addition to our classic normal
mode legendary is our tougher
aspirational version of the campaign
where the enemies hit harder
and respawning is heavily restricted so
every battle is a gut punch every boss
is a worthy adversary it's gonna hurt
you might tap out but if you persist and
you get to the end your time will be
well rewarded whether you want to play
solo or with a fire team the difficulty
will scale based on how many people you
bring
before we go one last trip down memory
lane i remember camping out the predator
for destiny 1 because i just had to have
the ghost to me it was like the symbol
of destiny and if you care about that
stuff like me you're going to want to
get your hands on the collector's
edition because you're going to get a
hive buddy to go up on the shelf with it
[Music]
[Music]
wow that was so cool i'm so i'm so
excited for this one and that's not even
everything that's in there too i know
those are the hero items and they're i
think one of the best ones that we've
ever done
collector's editions have always been
like this really perfect jumping point
to enter the worlds that we build and
actually lifting like in-world objects
and putting them in players hands is
just it's just a good feeling we don't
just put random items everything in
there means something and it helps push
the narrative and there might be some
puzzles to unlock in there as well
so at this point you can see sabathune
has been one of our greatest threats
operating behind the scenes for years
you may have heard of her brother the
taken king but savathun is the most
dangerous being we've ever faced she's
cunning elusive she works in the shadows
so in a way sabathun is new to all of us
exactly and now it's time to finally see
this legend reveal herself and change
the destiny universe forever
but when we talk about the overarching
story of destiny we don't just mean the
plot lines or characters that feature
released release narrative is a guiding
force in destiny and we're calling on
its rich history of world building
bringing that to the forefront and
growing it in a bold new direction so
when you join the game today you'll
experience an immediate call to action
alongside millions of your fellow
guardians during this past year we
watched the results of your actions play
out across destiny's seasonal releases
you've redeemed old foes brought former
enemies to the bargaining table learned
that there's always more than one side
to every story and built alliances no
one ever thought possible and on the
largest scale you'll experience a vast
living interconnected world of stories
that's driving to a greater end we need
you
you'll experience this alongside a
massive community of guardians release
after release together this is our
universe's cosmic purpose this 10-year
journey we've been on since destiny 1
it's drawing to its dramatic conclusion
the light and darkness saga will end
but make no mistake destiny 2 will not
we're building not so much to an ending
but more to this transformative moment
for destiny 2's future last year we
announced the witch queen and the
following expansion lightfall and now
we're excited to announce the release
after lightfall the final chapter in the
light and darkness saga
destiny 2
the final shape
it's going to be one wild continuous
ride yes and that ride starts with
season of the lost not only is it the
prologue to the witch queen it's your
first opportunity to interact with
sabathune but
rather than spoil it for you why don't
we take a look
if we are to survive the coming storm
the tower and the dreaming city must
stand united
we are surrounded a ring of spears
pointing inward from the edges of our
system
the witch queen is no less dangerous now
than she has ever been we must uncover
whatever secrets she knows with the time
that we have
[Music]
we light the pathways of the ascendant
plane and guide my people back to me
there is a malevolent force at work in
this plane guarding
[Music]
your knack for violence is needed
[Music]
[Music]
perhaps with them i can save us all
[Music]
seasons have gone through massive
transformations since shadow keep we're
dedicated to creating an evolving
interconnected world that puts your
guardian at the center of the action
we're reaching the end of one journey
and the beginning of another the days of
destiny's biggest story moments
happening in lore pages is long gone i
mean mara's return has been hinted at
forever and now it's happening in a
season
one of the changes i'm most excited
about are the updates to the light
subclasses every season in year five of
destiny 2 riding aspects and fragments
similar to stasis we'll be starting with
a void subclass update that goes live
alongside the witch queen
but the witch queen is only the
beginning of what's to come and season
of the lost is the prologue to that
story it starts off with marisov's
return to the dreaming city and with her
return all the awoken technology comes
alive
but the hive god of war zebra wrath has
re-emerged and has guardians and mara
and her sights guardians must forge a
path through the ascendant plane to save
mars lost covenant of witches before
zebra wrath can reach them and to aid
you in this task you'll have the
wayfinder's compass the time is at hand
the beacon is shining bright and the ley
lines are set in place
it's an ancient awoken artifact that
gives the wielder the power to uncover
pathways secrets and treasures within
the ascendant plane
there's a plethora of new weapons coming
including a suite of legendary stasis
guns that will stop your enemies cold
[Music]
the armor makes you feel like you're a
member of queen mars court and no season
is complete without new exotics and
season velocity features one once
intended for aldrin
let's take a moment to talk about trials
so trials of osiris is the end game
aspirational pvp activity and more
popular than ever two of the biggest ass
from our community have been adding
anti-cheat and adding matchmaking in
season to lost we're doing both we've
partnered with battlely to soft launch
the anti-cheat software when trials goes
live on september 10th
also you'll be able to match make with
groups of players to form fire teams or
solo queue by yourself and we've remixed
how rewards are distributed to give all
players the opportunity to earn some of
the best weapons and coolest armor in
the game that's right we're shifting
away from winning matches as a primary
way to earn loot and instead winning
individual rounds and completing matches
will allow you to earn some rewards but
going flawless hasn't changed so if you
want to flex those pvp skills the
flawless chest will still be the only
place to earn a depth trials weapons and
unique cosmetics
all right so the next chapter in destiny
begins right after this stream with
season of the loss return to the
dreaming city with marasov and learn the
mystic art of wayfinding i'm so excited
cross play is going live today and today
is your first opportunity to jump into
destiny with friends on any platform
from all over the world playing together
[Music]
and to leave the world in a better place
we want to be a part of that social
change [ __ ] racism
we don't just stop with the games that
we make but we really utilize the
successes that we've seen to be able to
give back in an even greater capacity
that spans beyond just the gaming
industry
foundation thank you
[Music]
pressing button for live
adventure has begun
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this game is going to single-handedly
destroy my social life and i can't wait
[Music]
[Music]
all right guardian time to kick them
where it hurts
dogs
how do you follow that wow
30 years and i i remember when halo
first launched and my friends and i
completed the entire campaign in a
single epic play session and as the
credits rolled i knew that bungie had
transformed console gaming forever and
that i would be a lifelong fan yeah
changed how we played games too i
remember getting together with friends
for halo week and lan parties we had so
much fun
and 30 years of bungee games is
something special it's something worth
celebrating together so we're going to
have a party in destiny 2.
starting this december we are launching
the bungee 30th anniversary celebration
in destiny 2. free for all players the
30th anniversary celebration will offer
a new six player matchmade activity
secrets to unravel and rewards that
commemorate our long and storied history
together and that's just the beginning
in addition to the free event players
can also purchase the bungie 30th
anniversary pack that includes a new
treasure-themed three-player dungeon set
on the cosmodrome within the fabled loot
cave players will plunder its depth to
discover an exciting new thorn inspired
armor set and fan favorite destiny one
weapons like izaluna and thousand yard
stare it even has the claymore sword
from myth purchase in the pack unlocks a
range of awesome bungee themed armor
ornaments and cosmetics to collect
including ornament sets inspired by the
bungee 30th anniversary celebration and
marathon but the dungeon holds one more
secret the crown jewel of its weaponry
is a destiny one classic galahorn is
making its long-awaited debut in destiny
2.
we're going to take its iconic status to
the next level galley has been carefully
updated for the destiny 2 sandbox so
this december join your friends and
collect exclusive rewards during the
bungee 30th anniversary celebration but
the party isn't only happening in
destiny 2. we've partnered with nerf
limited to create a functional dart
firing gallo horn we'll have more on
that soon and that's not all here's a
look at some of the incredible loot
we've made over the years and a sneak
peek of what's coming up
[Music]
wow lorraine i can't believe we're
celebrating bungie's 30th anniversary 30
years it's incredible yeah i mean look
think of all the games and products that
have come out over these years yeah
starting operation desert storm pathways
into darkness
marathon myth oni halo and destiny seven
years of destiny it's an amazing journey
so excited you know we have a lot of
really cool stuff coming up and a lot of
other things in the works of course as
always but yeah i mean what do we have
we have the fallen captain statue which
is incredible and then we have the
helmet celestial knight thing is so cool
yeah and my favorite the arcadia jump
ship yeah i get goosebumps just thinking
about that you know it really gives me
that nostalgia from destiny one and so i
think it's a great way that we're gonna
celebrate not only bungie's 30-year
heritage but the seven-year heritage of
destiny yeah and it definitely gives you
the feels
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for being on this journey with
us whether it started this year or 30
years ago we've just started talking
about the witch queen today you've got
our first peak at weapon crafting our
definitively destiny campaign the glaive
and a year full of updates to all our
light base type classes all of this and
more is coming alongside savathun's
long-awaited arrival front and center to
the destiny universe
the witch queen marks an acceleration in
our story heading towards the conclusion
of the light and dark saga and we're so
excited for everyone to join us on this
epic adventure in the witch queen
lightfall the final shape and beyond
and the witch queen's gonna kick off
another amazing year of destiny with
four great seasons packed with all of
the narrative events and rewards that
you've come to expect from us but
there's even more coming next year than
just our new seasons
the deluxe edition of the witch queen
will also include two brand new dungeons
to be released in 2022 and we're also
going to be remastering another classic
destiny one raid and releasing it free
for all players this means going forward
starting this december with our 30th
anniversary event there will be a new
piece of raider dungeon content in the
game every three months
in 2022 we will also be adding legacy
rotations for rage and dungeons meaning
every week there will be new ways to
earn rewards in both the latest and
greatest content and raids and dungeons
from the past if you love amazing
in-game content we want to prove that no
other game offers more quality and more
variety than destiny 2.
we hope that you've enjoyed a look in
the future of destiny 2. which queen
pre-orders are available wherever you
play destiny cross-play is live on all
devices and season of the lost kicks off
today
see you in
games is a funny thing
who decides what is true
tell me little lights
what is your truth now
[Music]
the witch queen is no less dangerous now
than she has ever been
[Music]
prepare for what is inevitably to come
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you